ciao rivers e benvenuti nuovissimo a
grande richiesta oggi parliamo di
università e da tantissimo tempo infatti
che vi chiedete di raccontarvi la mia
esperienza universitaria questo video si
dividerà in due parti prima vi
racconterò il mio percorso universitario
e dopo cercherò di rispondere a più
domande possibili che mi avete fatto
riguardo l'università partiamo subito
per raccontarvi il mio percorso
universitario dobbiamo partire dalla
maturità
di recente ho realizzato un video
proprio su questo argomento sulla mia
maturità che vi lascio qui quindi se non
avete ancora visto
andatelo a vedere perché partiamo dalla
maturità perché durante l'esame orale
tutti i nostri professori ci hanno detto
preparatevi la classica domanda ma dopo
cosa vuoi fare che università vuoi
frequentare
quindi io me ne sono uscita con economia
allora chi mi conosce sa che dio e i
numeri siamo due cose due rette che non
si incontreranno mai io e tutto ciò che
riguarda la scienza il mondo scientifico
non ci incontreremo mai quindi io non lo
so perché ho detto economia arriva
settembre io entro nel panico
essenzialmente il motivo principale di
questa mia confusione post maturità e
era il fatto che io volevo andare a
vivere a new york
il mio sogno era frequentare
un'accademia di performing arezzo quindi
fare canto danza e recitazione
dall'altra parte del mondo ma non ci
sono andata per varie ragioni e quindi
mi sono trovata costretta a scegliere un
università insomma da frequentare
il torino e qui arriva il primo
clamoroso errore quindi stavano per
iniziare le lezioni panico dio dove mi
scrivo dove non vi scrivo la mia amica
del liceo si è iscritta a giurisprudenza
e io dico tagliamo la testa al toro
iscriviamoci pure noi a giurisprudenza
anche se sinceramente già in partenza
non mi interessava proprio errore della
vita
volete sapere quanto sono durata la
facoltà di giurisprudenza due mesi forse
quindi dopo due mesi ho deciso di
abbandonare perché per quanto mi
riguarda era troppo noioso pesante non
c'era niente di artistico ma questo
giustamente voi mi direte dove saperlo
già da prima però vabbè io l'ho provata
mi sono buttata e mi raccomando molto
importante se vi accorgete che quel
percorso di studi non fa assolutamente
per voi ma abbandonate prima che sia
troppo tardi quindi dovete assolutamente
scegliere un percorso universitario che
gli stimoli che viviamo cia e che vi
appassioni chiusa la parentesi
giurisprudenza mi ributto nell'oceano
della confusione perché comunque dovevo
trovare un'alternativa ormai l'anno
accademico era iniziato e io anche
personalmente stavo tentando un momento
abbastanza critico quindi vi lascio
immaginare qual era il mio cud in questo
mood di confusione totale
purtroppo mi sono seduta mi sono seduta
perché non avevo la forza o la voglia di
rimettermi in gioco e quindi ho deciso
di prendermi un anno sabbatico
secondo errore clamoroso da non fare mai
in quindi durante questo anno io mi sono
letteralmente versa è data alla pazza
gioia uscì con tutte le se andava
parlare tutte le sere ovviamente mia
mamma tutti i giorni però faceva notare
barra pesare giustamente la svolta
arriva quando decido di iscrivermi ai
provini di xfactor
la svolta non arriva perché una volta
fatto il casting poi sono stata presa
perché ovviamente non sono stata presa
ma arriva perché il provino era a
cinisello balsamo di ciro milano e non
si sa perché una volta finito il provino
non ancora covito sera organizzato meno
mia mamma mi guarda e mi dice andiamo a
vedere un'università cosa questo è un
fuori programma mamma lei aveva visto
queste università presto su internet e
era presa benissimo devono vedere magari
ti piace la facoltà in questione era
scienze della comunicazione
noi arriviamo quindi queste università
che era immensa rispetto a quella che
aveva frequentato a torino iniziamo a
informarci insomma sui vari corsi io
rimango abbagliata quando vedo tra le
materie di studio cinema e io neanche
immaginavo che all'università si potesse
studiare cinema quindi questa cosa un po
mi fa dire che però potrei pensarci mia
mamma una volta tornata a torino mi dice
senti ti è piaciuta questa università
ti interessa quel quel percorso di studi
iscriviti scrivo subito farò devi
deciderlo per l'iniziale elezioni
panico quindi io ci penso un attimo e
sinceramente mi ero anche stufata di non
fare niente tutto il giorno di
cazzeggiare passatemi il termine tutto
il giorno e soprattutto di sentire mia
mamma che si lamentava tutto il giorno e
quindi ho detto iscriviamoci quindi mi
iscrivo scienze della comunicazione in
particolare il mio corso era
comunicazione media e pubblicità la cosa
super positiva che ai tempi non avevo
neanche perdi inquadrato era sì il fatto
di iniziare un percorso universitario e
quindi provare a vedere se questa volta
era la strada giusta ma soprattutto il
fatto di trasferirvi in un'altra città
quando sono partita da torino infatti
ero super apatica era un momento come vi
ho detto già prima abbastanza piatto non
avevo stimoli arrivo a milano e iniziò
le elezioni e vi giuro cioè non lo dico
così avrò la mia vita è cambiata da così
a così la nota che si abituata sempre
vede la stessa gente sempre gli stessi
posti cioè cambiare totalmente
prospettiva vi assicuro che rivoluziona
la vita quindi mio consiglio se siete in
dubbio appunto sul trasferirvi o meno in
una nuova città per studiare
io vi dico sì assolutamente fatelo
perché è un'esperienza formativa che mi
aiuterà a crescere ea maturare
tantissimo passiamo al cuore del video
cioè vi voglio riassumere in breve i
miei tre anni universitari il primo anno
delirio totale perché arrivo
all'università il sacco di amici e
quindi uscite anche durante la settimana
uscite nei weekend feste universitarie
terzo errore clamoroso da non fare il
primo anno
cazzeggiare troppo e studiare poco
perché gli esami che non date il primo
anno non è che spariscono veli li
trovate poi negli anni successivi quindi
mi raccomando
pensateci bene e organizzatevi bene il
secondo anno c'è stato un cambiamento è
radicale perché sono tornata ai tempi
del liceo quindi frequentavo tutte le
elezioni anche quelle al mattino presto
di venerdì e giovedì sera io uscivo
quindi secchiona ma senza rinunciare al
divertimento e mi ricordo che giovedì
sera c'era una serata universitaria top
della settimana
e io alle 9 del mattino il venerdì nero
a lezione a frequentare estetica del
cinema il terzo anno è stato l'anno del
datti una mossa se no non ti laurei
perché avevo degli esami arretrati dal
primo al secondo anno che dovevo
assolutamente dare per riuscire a
laurearmi insomma nel nei giusti tempi
tutti gli studenti universitari hanno
degli esami incubo quegli esami
insormontabili che sembrano delle
montagne che non riuscirai mai a scalare
i miei esami incubo sono stati economia
politica proprio l'ho odiata storia
contemporanea e sociologia picco
l'episodio super carino che vorrei
raccontarvi che riguarda la preparazione
dell'esame di economia politica allora
io ero nel panico totale
conosco una ragazza che aveva già dato
questo esame e aveva degli appunti
fantastici e tutti quelli a cui gli
aveva prestati erano riusciti a passare
questo esame
quindi lei non solo vi dagli appunti ma
si offre di aiutarlo di dargli
ripetizioni gratuitamente un angelo per
quanto riguarda la tesi alcuni di voi
già lo sanno perché ho risposto a una
domanda su instagram mi sono laureata in
cinema italiano ovviamente era insomma
la materia che ho seguito con più
dedizione e passione
il titolo era l'urbe sullo schermo la
rappresentazione di roma dal 1945 ad
oggi quindi analizzavo se non erro dieci
film girati a roma
alcuni anche molto recenti l'ultimo mi
sembra fosse la grande bellezza e perché
roma perché è una città che amo che
l'esempio è piaciuta un sacco e
soprattutto amo i film
insomma girati ambientati a roma quindi
ho unito le due cose ed è venuta fuori
la mia tesi
il giorno della mia tesi diciamo che non
ero al settimo cielo perché ero di nuovo
in un periodo un po no della mia vita
per problemi miei personali e quindi c'è
non la vedevo come oh mio dio festa mi
sono laureata yeah ma vabbè adesso mi
prendo salao ea voi vediamo cosa fare
della mia vita
quindi questo era good passiamo ora alle
vostre domande
prima domanda come studiavi per un esame
qual era il tuo metodo di studio
allora il mio metodo di studio si basa
sul fatto che la mia memoria è molto
visiva di dio anche al liceo ero
abituato a fare così mi leggevo il
capito il paragrafo di riferimento meno
riassumeva sul mio quaderno poi
prendendo da conte lezione di integrato
il tutto con gli appunti che avevo preso
lezione quindi alla fine studiavo quello
che c'era sul mio quaderno quindi la
sintetica
il libro di testo e gli appunti presi in
classe
hai mai avuto dei momenti di crisi è mai
pensato di abbandonare allora
assolutamente sì non è salvo un percorso
proprio facilissimo perché spesso
appunto pensavo che comunque il mio
obiettivo il mio sogno era un altro e
magari quell'università non mi avrebbe
portato lì ma
la prima crisi più grossa è arrivata
praticamente a metà di questo percorso
universitario e quindi visto comunque
avevo già dato un sacco di esami ero già
un bel pezzo avanti ho detto tengo duro
e comunque mi laureo è una laurea è
sempre qualcosa in più bisogna scegliere
l'università secondo di ciò che hai
fatto cambiare totalmente il riso il mio
consiglio è scegliere l'università in
base a quello che vi piacerebbe fare
dopo quindi seguire i vostri interessi
le vostre passioni e studiare qualcosa
che vi piaccia a studiare perché se al
liceo eravate tra virgolette obbligati a
studiare determinate materie
all'università potete scegliere le
materie che sono più compatibili con il
vostro percorso di studi con le vostre
passioni sei mai stata bocciata un esame
ebbene sì volete sapere quale same al
primo esame che ho dato nel corso di
comunicazione media pubblicità mi ero
preparata benissimo ma ho avuto la sfiga
e capiterà purtroppo a tanti di voi di
beccare l'assistente inacidita dalla
vita da stronza di turno che mi ha
massacrato e mi ricordo che ho chiamato
mia mamma piangendo perché ero convinta
di passarlo era fi l'emozione del primo
esame che dai mamma mi hanno bocciato e
quindi i pianti e le crisi poi la mente
lo ridato con un cubo grazie a dio con
un altro assistente l'ho passato però
capita ragazzi è normale restarci male
sul momento perché comunque dopo tanta
preparazione speri di passarlo però
capita a tutti se beccate nello stronzo
di turno purtroppo che smagliante la
fama che sei andata fuori corso allora
no ho fatto di tutto per non andare
fuori corso
in primis perché voleva laurearmi il
prima possibile e poi per perché mi
sarebbe dispiaciuto nei confronti dei
miei genitori che comunque mi hanno
sostenuto negli studi e andare fuori
corso vuol dire pagare in più senza
motivo alla fine perché se riesci a non
andare fuori corso è tanto di guadagnato
per tutti quindi non sono andata fuori
corso hai mai lavorato durante
l'università
sì ho fatto dei piccoli lavoretti per
arrotondare ho fatto lo stesso per
eventi e congressi
ho fatto una vocalist in discutere cup
orecchie volte e ho lavorato come pr
anche in discoteca e
diciamo che il lavoro un po meno carino
è stato dare volantini fuori dalle
discoteche all'uscita dalle discoteche
quindi alle 4 del mattino dove usciva di
tutto e di più gente ubriaca agente
fatta e mi insultavano senza motivo
veniva beh quello è stato veramente
testa un po dolente del mio percorso
lavorativo
consiglieresti percorso universitario a
chi magari ha le idee confuse
allora chi meglio di me può rispondere a
questa domanda allora io penso che
comunque la una laurea sia appunto una
cosa in più che fa comunque curriculum
ovvio se studiate qualcosa che li
interessa mi piace e che sapete che vi
può portare verso il lavoro somma dei
vostri sogni
meglio se però siete confusi e comunque
a mio avviso meglio prendersi comunque
una laurea e poi vedere se nel magari
col tempo il destino vi porterà pure a
fare quello che volete hai mai avuto un
momento di black out durante un esame
dove non ti ricordare assolutamente
nulla ebbene sì ho avuto anche questo
era un esame di estetica del cinema io
come vi ho detto prima frequentavo tutte
le elezioni hanno preparatissima
all'esame non so perché l'agitazione non
lo so
black out totale non ricordavo più nulla
e sono stata graziata
anche questa volta dalla professoressa
che mi aveva visto tutte le elezioni
prendere appunti e quindi mi ha aiutato
a facendovi delle domande un po più
facili mettendovi a mio agio facendomi
tranquillizzare perché aveva capito
ovviamente che era un momento di panico
ma io avevo studiato avevo frequentato
quindi ero preparata anno sabbatico sì o
no assolutamente consiglio proprio
questo sì la vostra sorella maggiore no
perché uno dice mi prendono sabbatico
così penso meglio probably è una
cavolata perché comunque finisci per
voluto uscire tutti i giorni cazzeggiare
e non ti focalizzi sul vero obiettivo è
no soprattutto perché ve lo dico perché
l'ho provato su me stessa riprendere a
studiare dopo un anno di pausa
devastante io ho avuto una difficoltà
tremenda arrivo in terminal sui libri o
studiare perché avevo proprio perso il
giro non ero più abituata a studiare a
memorizzare perdevo subito la
concentrazione quindi vi prego vi prego
non prendetevi una cosa particolare amo
arrivati purtroppo alla fine del video
spero tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto
spero che tanti di voi si siano rivisti
nella mia esperienza nel mio racconto e
che altrettanti di voi utilizzino questi
miei consigli e suggerimenti per le
vostre scelte future
ho cercato di rispondere a più domande
possibili ma mi raccomando se ne avete
altre
mandatemi dei direct io sarò ben felice
di rispondergli e di darvi dei consigli
se non l'avete ancora fatto ricordatevi
iscrivervi al canale di cliccare sulla
campanella che trovate il vicino ad asso
l'iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati per essere i primi a vedere
come andare in esilio seguitemi inoltre
su tutti gli altri social facebook
instagram tik tok io vi mando un bacione
ci vediamo al prossimo video
ciao
[Musica]